foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning everyone
so I would like all of you to imagine
being in a workplace where you're
dealing with thousands of calls
thousands of customer escalations
thousands of high volume High Velocity
workload
right
High attrition
out of sync processes
so these organizations any organization
that's going through this kind of
situation is called high volume High
Velocity organization
these organizations deal with crisis
like situations on a regular basis
these organizations can be any kind of
organization they can be Financial
retail government non-governmental
organizations
no matter what the organization type
the leaders in these organizations are
struggling to motivate the employees to
work towards a common goal
for last 16 years I've been helping such
organizations transform
my experience does not come from work
alone my family has a good
representation in Military and space
research
so I've grown up hearing stories of how
these organizations help and motivate
the employees to work towards a common
goal
based on my experience I've identified
three basic things that a leader can do
to motivate the employees
to work towards very complex and
uncertain goals
I call them three C's so while I
introduce those three C's I'll be
sharing military tradition and Military
stories
and the reason is because I believe both
military and these organizations they're
both trying to train the employees to
handle crisis-like situations
so before I get into
the discussion or introduce you to three
C's I also want to touch upon PPD
framework which stands for people
process and Technology
when it comes to process and Technology
they are very domain specific and of
course a ton of materials out there so
today in my talk I'll be focusing more
on the people part of the problem
because I believe if you take care of
the people part of the problem the magic
automatically happens
so with that let's start with the first
C which I call camaraderie
camaraderie means French friendship
right being having a friend
it can be described as a situation where
this trust between employees
now why is it important because it
Fosters productivity collaboration
increased efficiency
now according to 2021 survey more than
50 of the employees said they enjoyed
their workplace because they have a good
friend
let me share a story military story here
which showcase just to Showcase like how
military tries to build camaraderie
among the employees
so this story is about a young officer
who's just about a week into his
training
and he's approached by his training
officer so the trainee ends up sharing
uh his concerns about the quality of
food in the cafeteria
so the training officer the following
morning
he wakes up the third year batch the
cinemas batch in that Academy few
minutes early makes them run 20 rounds
and informs on that they're being
punished because they're not aware of
the concerns of the new batch
what does the third year bash do the
following morning they wake up the
second year batch few minutes early
make them run 20 rounds and inform them
that they've been punished because
they're not aware of the consists on new
batch
so what this lot that you can take away
from the story
and some of the things that can be
applied to the corporate world is the
importance of collective accountability
or responsibility
so when you design a campaign or a bash
in your organization you want to
consider the team goal in addition to
individual goals
when it comes to Celebration you got to
celebrate team success in addition to
individual success
every time you roll out a new
decision you want to follow up with a
survey
and of course you have to act on the
survey too whatever you learn you want
to react to that with urgency
and last but not the least do not forget
to empower your team
so I'm pretty sure if you follow these
guidelines you can definitely build
build camaraderie in your team
and that concludes the first C let's
move on to the second C
which is what I call connection or
engagement
it can be described as a situation where
the employee has a sense of belonging
and the sense of belonging is considered
as as basic as food shelter and safety
it Fosters an environment which is happy
and healthy and less stressful
let me share a military tradition here
or how military tries to build a
connection among the employees so this
called rum punch so in this tradition
the officers take out this subordinates
out for drinks the subordinates allowed
to vent out they are allowed to raise
grievances around past decisions
the ground rule is that subordinates
will not be punished or penalized for
their misbehavior
now the goal of such tradition is to
Foster connection
right suppose covet in the corporate
world it's become even more important
for leaders to connect with the
employees
one of the things you could do is being
more transparent so in the post-covet
world during covet you would have
observed that Airlines industry which
was losing millions of dollars a day and
they didn't know how they're going to
come out of this situation they chose to
over communicate
so communication transparency is really
critical some of the other things you
got to do regular check-ins
you want to be more you want to show
Integrity in your actions
you have to create platforms where
people come together both physical and
virtually you want to organize events
all these in addition to traditional
methods of one-on-ones huddles and news
newsletters
so I'm pretty sure if you follow all
this you can build connection and
improve engagement in your organization
which I want to talk about is culture so
it's a pretty big topic but I want to
leave you with one small thing that has
always done magic in my organization
which is to create an environment where
you reward motivated and driven
employees
I'll give you an example let's say you
have an opportunity to send two of your
employees to a conference
now there's two ways you could go about
it one is to nominate the others to
select
the problem with nomination is that the
employee that you select or or identify
they may or may not be motivated to go
to those conferences
even when they go they may or may not do
a great job but imagine if you have a
selection process where you identify
those are truly motivated the chances
are when they go to these conferences
they do an awesome job moreover when
they come back and if you have them
share the experience with a larger
population now you motivated the next
set of people who are motivated and
driven and ready to go for such events
the following year
so that concludes my third C
and I want to really understand the
importance of these three C's right so
if you try to build an environment where
you have your employees have a great
friend they feel have a sense of
belonging and a culture which is driven
and rewarding is rewards The Driven
employees then you build a very strong
foundation and this strong Foundation is
really important for you to move on to
the next phase of your transformation
which is tweaking your processes or
bring introducing new technology and
I've seen most of the transformation and
most of the projects and programs failed
because they've you know the leaders
fail to understand the importance of
taking care of the people part of the
problem
and with that I conclude and thank you
for the opportunity and good luck with
your transformation thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]